we've been in the topic of similarity
one of the instances in real life that
we tore our similarity was you want to
draw staff that represents much much
bigger things as a most common example
which we already look at this maps
you're looking at that and we used to
reading max receivers before and
obviously they're much much smaller
representation of what you got they
retain all the same does anyone remember
Scylla figures they retain two things in
their original and they change size they
have the same
you talk about a fish one shape and it's
an original and it's similar figure you
want to get the same will see scale is a
lot of thing you can keep the same right
I mean probably what you mean is the
proportions of the shape like this side
is meant to be twice as long as this one
right where would be a look at the
similar figure the saga will be twice as
long again right so you got proportions
and then you've got features remember
that right so if you go triangle then
end up with a triangle three sizes three
sides force us at whatever ok so it maps
do this all the features all the
proportions are the same but it's just
shrunk down today we're going to have a
look at building plans which are kind of
quite a specialized sort of map and then
but all these different sort of sub has
sort of knowledge to understand so
building plans what makes up a building
play there are sort of two main parts of
it and they each come from a different
perspective ok so this sounds a bit
fainter call this way but the first part
of the booty plans aren't players and
what we mean is a top-down view maybe
that's even worth writing for yourself
right when we say plans just by
themselves what we mean is a top-down
view
so you're like no birds are flying over
the top what are the different outlines
obviously okay so this is the plans the
year this other set of things that goes
along with it because of course if
you've got like their two-story or a
three story or whatever story building
then looking at it from the sign off
from the front and seeing its elevation
how tall is what's the profile look like
that gives you a very very different
picture so you've got a top-down view
and then you go to elevation which
basically shows the profile and the
Heinz
ok but then within plans and elevations
you can break it down a little further
and all of these which the reason why we
have so many of these is because these
are really useful you might think wait
like I'm going to be an architect yeah
you most of you probably were not and
that's fine you are going to likely live
somewhere though and you're probably are
going to get a plan the building plan of
where you're going to move and you are
actually want to deal with interpret
like what does that look like the
bathrooms there and you there and all of
these sites and what have you which
leads me to the first different of the
first two parts of it plans which are
you're going to get what's called a site
plan isn't site player okay the cyclin
so in other words you're interested in a
building but it's got a context right
it's got a block okay so on that block
with my colleague on the block you've
got like surrounding buildings you might
have you know a garden all of these
kinds of things etc like a garage that
might be separate or shed whatever all
these things form the context for your
building right on the block and then
secondly you look inside of you this is
outside the building and then there's an
inside which we call the plan
and this is probably what you're
visualizing right so this means i want
to know like what a bruise what are the
different features where are the windows
and doors so you can probably see in
this dabble their students bruise okay
so all of that is thinking from the top
down and looking at everything so you
can see it all laid out nicely now I
want to come back to elevations right
now remember i mentioned it shows the
profile shows type but depending on
which angle you're looking from you'll
get our different elevation have really
really ordinary names and we have what
we call our front elevation which is if
you're steady as the name suggests at
the front of building and just looking
at it and then secondly bless you can
anyone give me what they reckon would be
the other side a side elevation
generally speaking of buildings front
and back elevations will be pretty much
the same thing but mirror right whereas
a side elevation that might tell you for
instance in my house my house is really
long so that gives you a lot of
meaningful information that the front of
version doesn't tell me this is your top
down view ok when they talk a front
elevation of a side elevation by
convention even though why should it be
this way the convention is for isometric
view that the front elevation is coming
from the left ok so this is me standing
over here looking at that side whereas
the side elevation is standing kind of
over here and looking from the right 2
times ok does that make sense so one of
the things that I always do when I was
drawing these diagrams is I would just
roll a little man and I saw on that here
just here by myself and give me a visual
this is the front for them okay and if
you like that okay now secondly have a
look at this up number two is where
we're going to spend most our time
together okay for number two and you can
see here are the actual questions for
number two in a second you've got your
diagram there but you need to get it a
particular size ok now let's actually
think this through because I had to do
this so I think you guys can probably
work it out being dad like this comes
from a bubble things come from a book
they've got some distances on here some
legs I've got some legs and then it also
provides you a scale now since they give
you both of those even without the
physical book in front of you you should
be able to work out and i'll give you
the easiest one you should be able to
work out how much one of these links
should be on your computer screen ok now
what I'm going to go for is this one
here let me zoom in so you can see it a
little bit clearer it's as 4 meters
right for minute and the scale is one to
four hundred in other words is for plan
or i should say this sapphire got the
whole block this sigh plane is 400 times
smaller than the real thing ok so
therefore on your screen or if you had a
book when you're born how long is this
supposed to be on your page
I think about it right I'm 4 meters four
meters is 400 centimeters right 400 mm
but the diagram is supposed to be four
hundred times smaller than 470 right so
what am I going to do I'm going to take
this distance and i'm going to divide by
four hundred to get a real distance so
therefore i want you to look at your
screen and actually use your ruler
because I defeating around with mine to
get it to exactly this I want you to
make this length zoom in or out to such
a point so that when you put your or a
lot on the width of this driveway
driveway it should be exactly one
centimeter or as close as you can
together you might need to go to your
percentages cuz when you go ctrl + ctrl
minus whatever it'll jump up and down in
like ten percent 25% whatever you're
probably gonna have to be a little more
flight on that and very likely because
your computer screens are all different
sizes you'll have a different percentage
to the person sitting next to